in berlin lagen die mieten bei
neuvermietungen zuletzt im schnitt 34
prozent über der gesetzlichen obergrenze
und die sich offenbar keine sau hält
falls sie zu hause wirklich keine
einzige immobilie besitzen ist das echo
von im prenzlauer berg hatten war die
letzten jahre immer eine wertsteigerung
von rund zehn prozent jährlich
das heißt also nichts tun bei so einer
immobilie bringt auch jedes jahr ein
paar hunderttausend euro rendite mit
arbeit reich werden kann jeder
ja es ist natürlich alles total legitim
jetzt aber die schlechte nachricht ende
2017 gab es in deutschland 600.000
baugenehmigungen die auf ihre umsetzung
warten in ballungsgebieten ort nämlich
investoren baugenehmigungen und bauen
dann nicht weil sie auf die preise der
zukunft setzen ja stopp der baumeister
sagt sich warum jetzt bauen wenn ich
später noch reicher werden
eigentum verpflichtet mai es machen wir
uns nichts vor unser land leidet unter
einer schlimmen sucht es ist eins der
größten probleme unserer zeit immer mehr
deutsche bestehen darauf zu wohnen
sie geben fast ihr ganzes geld fürs
wohnen aus warum wohnen ist doch
stinklangweilig
manche senioren wohnen praktisch den
ganzen tag was das kostet deshalb hör
auf zu wohnen jetzt eine initiative der
aktion keine macht dem wohnen
tabuthema
immer mehr deutsche bestehen darauf zu
wohnen und verantwortlich immerhin hat
der staat endlich reagiert und das
sogenannte baukindergeld eingeführt da
ist die neue gruppe wahnsinnig stolz
drauf da kriegen familien pro jahr und
kind 1200 euro zehn jahre also
gutverdiener familien die sich einen
hausbau leisten können das ist so
sinnvoll als ob unicef patenschaften für
das neue royale baby anbieten würde
schreiben sie jetzt ist ein kleiner
prinz
ich behaupte boden ist das neue gold
dennis knossalla es gut er hat sich
mehrere grundstücke rund um köln hat er
erbt dennis was haben sie denn zurzeit
im angebot
gut dass sie fragen nach welche ich
hätte diesen absoluten familientraum ein
weitläufiges 150 quadratmeter grundstück
zum spottpreis von 350.000 euro
360.000 es geht ihnen minütlich hoch
drei ikea und die sondermülldeponie sind
fußläufig erreichbar als
grundstückseigentümer bin ich mit meiner
sozialen verantwortung natürlich bewusst
deshalb verkaufe ich auch nicht einfach
an den meistbietenden nein ich lasse die
beiden meistbietenden um das grundstück
spielen bei das ehepaar hensel spielt
gegen die kramp am ende kriegt einer das
grundstück und die anderen bleiben nur
die harten greet mit garten unser erstes
spiel bei antrag stellen in deutschland
so gut wie möglich die männer füllen
bauanträge aus entsprechend der
bauordnung lärmschutz energetische
dämmung brandschutz barrierefreiheit
dachbegrünung stellplätze für fahrräder
steht mir zu für autos ein
bürokratischer alptraum
und dann müssen die mädels die anträge
rechtzeitig zur post bringen
punkt für die kramers sauber weg
so fürchtet der grundstückspreis 380.000
euro nächsten runde auf die fresse
die männer müssen wir wiederholen
während sich die frauen gegenseitig mit
riesen wattestäbchen aus dem grundstück
prügel geil was hat das denn bitte mit
bauen zu tun aber sieht lustig aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mich haben beide nicht überzeugt aber
jetzt geht's um die wurst die noch
kinderlosen paare versuchen auf die
schnelle anbau kindergeld zu kommen wir
spielen da liefen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
verstanden
dass wir zu blöd denn das kloster damen
und herren